(gentle upbeat music)
♪ I need a do-over, how
did we end up this way ♪
♪ I'm so confused, lover,
did I mistake love and pain ♪
♪ Ain't got no shine
left, I couldn't hide it ♪
♪ I almost lost all my light ♪
♪ And I didn't choose sober,
but my eyes can't look away ♪
♪ I see our true colors, lately,
we've been lookin' gray ♪
♪ I can't turn back now, 'cause
you'd take me back down ♪
♪ That road that always seems
to come right back around ♪
♪ Remember when ♪
♪ We had dreams to fly away ♪
♪ But that was then ♪
♪ And now our story's just a page ♪
♪ Like a chill in my
bones when you say to me ♪
♪ What you say to me ♪
♪ I thought I found home,
but hidden underneath ♪
♪ We were crumblin' ♪
♪ No shootin' stars can
fix what we aren't ♪
♪ And what good's a lighthouse
when the light is burnin' out ♪
♪ And I feel what we
were washin' over me ♪
♪ Questionin' everything all that time ♪
♪ And I keep all the
ways that you wanted me ♪
♪ To be different fresh in my mind ♪
♪ What you loved, what you wanted ♪
♪ What you held so high when
we first met in hindsight ♪
♪ Were the things that you
tried and asked me to change ♪
♪ As if I could do that ♪
♪ Like a wave, you're
always crashin' into me ♪
♪ Crashin' into me ♪
♪ And these days are harder
than they used to be ♪
♪ And they used to be ♪
♪ No shootin' stars can
fix what we aren't ♪
♪ And what good's a lighthouse
when the light is burnin' out ♪
(audience cheering)